hey everyone welcome to the video here
in the November issue for 2019 vol 3
issue 11 so only one more issue left in
volume 3 before we turn the page to vol
4 in January 2020 so for this video it's
called returning to training after a
layoff and the subtext how to gradually
come back the right way so I think this
is a pretty cool topic in Mass
previously and I have them in the
references of this video we talked about
all the way back in volume 1 I think
issue 2 or 3 there was a written article
that I reviewed and it talked about how
skeletal muscle mass and strength were
resistant to two weeks of D training so
I've linked that article here in the
references and then I did another
article that talked about introductory
cycles and how to elicit the repeat
about a fact with introductory cycles
that are a little bit lighter than what
you would typically do in your normal
training block so that way when you jump
into your normal training block you
don't have too much damage and too much
fatigue from that training block so both
of those videos or excuse me both those
articles I think are related to this but
in this are this video here returning to
training after a layoff I want to talk
about a layoff for a long period of time
specifically we're going to give an
example that looks at a layoff of about
three months but there are times in our
life where school gets really busy work
gets really busy we have stuff in our
personal life and relationships get
really busy and we just don't have time
to train and we just simply don't make
it to the gym for a while and I think
that happens to more people than we know
tiss you know when we look at social
media typically people are just posting
their PRS they're not posting when they
have to take long periods of time off
from the gym
and what I think is important is if you
have to take a long period of time off
from the gym I don't think it's gonna
really crush you in the long run I think
what's important is how you come back
from that time off and that you do so
gradually and that you don't do too much
too soon so that's what this video is
all about when you have to take some
time off for those reasons not for
injury I don't consider myself an expert
on that so we're not going to cover
coming back from injuries but when you
have to take some time off time off here
how can you come back appropriately and
not do too much too soon
so today's objectives we're going to
examine first
rate of decline in strength and I
portray following time walk and what I
think we're gonna find out is that the
rate at which you lose muscle maps and
you lose strength when you have to take
significant time off a few months or so
it's not as much as most people think
you think oh I take you know two months
off and I'm just gonna look tiny and I'm
gonna just lose absolutely all of my
strength you know I'm going to lose 100
kilos on my list and I'm just gonna I'm
not going to be able to do anything and
that's just not the case I would say
that resistance training is is pretty
resistant to decreases in size and
strength even over three months or so
you're certainly going to lose some but
it's not as much as you might think so
first we're going to take a look at the
rate that I portray and strength decline
when you take time off from training
then want to understand when you start
to get back to training you need to be
cognizant of the fact that you're more
susceptible to muscle damage and you're
more susceptible for to fatigue also
your lifts just simply aren't at the
same place that they were even if you
don't lose a ton of strength you're
going to lose some so since you're more
susceptible to damage and you're going
to lose strength when you start back
we're going to talk about how to get
back from that I also understand that
the decrease in strength from the
assistance lifts might be different than
the decrease in strength in the main
lifts and there's some inconsistencies
on the literature on this but I do have
some some thoughts I'd like to share
specifically losing strength on a
machine based movement might not be as
much as losing strength on let's say a
squat well you also have to worry about
skill in addition to just worrying about
the strength and so then once we do all
of that and we talk about how much
strength and muscle mass people lose and
then understanding when you start back
that you're more susceptible to damage
what I want to do is to develop a full
program to get somebody back from a
layoff so in last month's video October
of 2019 volume 3 issue 10 we talked
about concurrent training for a marathon
and what I did for most of that video
was I put together a sample program that
someone could use so after we go over
the data and the science in the first
few slides of this what I've done here
again this month is to put together
another sample program that if you were
to have to take three months off of
training then
there's a three-month or a 13 week
program that that I've put together here
that can get you back to where you were
within those 13 weeks so one thing we
wanted to try to do in these videos is
to bring more practical examples to
everyone rather than just data so the
second half of this video is going to do
that and then during that time where we
have that program determine the general
guidelines for rebuilding volume
intensity and frequency and kind of
where your RP should be throughout the
process
so first let's get started with exactly
how much strength and size you lose
after the D training period and then
we'll go through that sample program to
start us back so the first study we want
to look at here is from Plaza [ __ ] in
2007 and this is one of the most
frequently cited studies I would say on
this and over the course of ten weeks
blaah sufficient colleagues had men and
women who had some training experience
not a lot but some training experience
and I will say right there I mean most
of the studies on training and D
training for long periods of time are on
individuals that are maybe
recreationally trained the reason being
is it's very difficult to get a trained
person to simply not train for three
months right I know most of us in here
if you you're interested in
participating in a scientific study and
I would certainly be as well but if I
was asked did not train for three months
that would be hard to do so it's
typically easier to get less trained
people from these studies but blogs of
Inchon colleagues have individuals and
either a concentric or eccentric
training group doing four sets a six by
six reps on leg extensions for ten weeks
both men and women they had control
groups here you can see control groups
if we're looking at strength or torque
here on the leg extension and the dashed
line over the course of 10 weeks didn't
change strength and we wouldn't expect
it to be but the individuals here that
trained in the calm centric Annie
centric groups we can see trained here
in the e centric and in the concent Rick
and they increase their strength after
the ten weeks which we would expect but
then this dashed line here that's three
months of D training and following that
three months of D training you can see
that strength does indeed decrease but
if I use the cursor and I just draw a
line straight across you can see that
this is at levels they decrease the
levels where they were at five weeks
right so they've lost a little less
than half of the adaptations or the
games that they act during these ten
weeks so training for ten weeks and
taking three months off taking three
months off you only lost about five
weeks of those games so yes that that
sucks right if you want to get back and
you want to keep training nobody wants
to have to lose that much strength but
five weeks can be made up in a
relatively quick timeframe so you do
lose some strength but it's not as much
as you might think on the right I think
is even more impressive so if we go over
to this figure now this is looking at I
purchase your muscle thickness of an
ultrasound measure and again we have the
control groups and the dash lines and
then the eccentric training group
increase their muscle size concentric
training group increases their muscle
size and then look at the D training yes
there's a trend to go down here but this
is actually a non significant decline
from this 10-week point to this point
after three months so they did lose some
but again if we draw this line we're
back to about the five-week level right
at least for these hundred group the
content group had a little bit of a
different time course so they're well
above the five-week level here but the
point is you do lose size and you do
lose strength but it's not as much as
you typically think so if you have to
take three months off of training well
that's probably not ideal if you think
of this as a long-term game five years
ten years twenty years that you're
training for that three months isn't
gonna mean a whole lot in the grand
scheme of things so if you have a really
busy time in your life and you do need
to do that
you're gonna lose strength in size but
it's not doesn't have to kill you
so another study older study here one of
the originals and this from staring in
1991 that it's an individual that's done
a lot of work on resistance training
this was in college-age women that had
some training experience as well and
they trained twice a week on the squad
at a six to eight RM or a ten to twelve
RM and they did have some other
movements that they were doing but this
was a long-term study in that they had
20 weeks of training then 30 weeks of D
training in six weeks of retraining so
the dashed line here everything to the
left of it represents this so this is
baseline this is following 20 weeks of
training following 30 weeks of D
training and then following six weeks of
retraining on the right here this is
just seven women who only did this
six weeks of retraining and a increased
strength and the goal is to compare that
to this but if we go over here to the
left side of this dashed line and we
take a look at the changes in squad the
time course of squat changes in these
women there was a 67% increase in
strength over the course of 20 weeks
again they weren't that well trained so
that's that's pretty reasonable
there was only a 13% decrease in
strength after taking those 30 weeks off
that shows that this this strength is
very resistant to dropping after only
decreasing 13% in 30 weeks there is
other data that shows a bit more and I
do think for the most part you would
probably lose a bit more so nobody
should take that 13% an absolute number
but I do think that it's it shows the
amount that you lose isn't going to be
some sort of astronomical amount if you
have to take a few months off that's
just going to be killer for a long
period of time and then when they
started the training after six weeks not
only did they get back to where they
were after the 20 weeks of training but
they even got a little bit better than
that but the main point being following
a large increase in strength after a
long period of really good training if
you take some months off in this case it
was 30 weeks you are gonna see a
decrease in strength but it's not going
to be a ton you will be able to make
that up in a couple months when you come
back so strength and size are pretty
resistant to decline now this is from
that same study and that same group of
women and it was looking at hypertrophy
as well so we're gonna see results here
similar to the blossom itch study where
if we just scroll back very quickly to
slides we can see a decrease in
hypertrophy after three months decrease
in my perjury or a decrease in muscle
thickness but it's not significant and
it's not a lot if we go back to the
staring study now we can see this just
showing from pre - 20 weeks of training
and then 20 weeks of training down to
after 30 weeks of D training so this is
type 1 fibers type 2 and then type 2b
type 2 acts so if we're looking at this
here we can see a 15% increase in size a
39 percent in a 47 percent so that's
what these numbers are 15 percent 13
in 47 and then over here we're seeing
the decreases after the D training so
type 1 fibers down 1% and then here
we're down 10% and then here were down
14% so clearly this is tending to
decrease the only significant decrease
was 14% but it does look like there's
certainly a clear trend for this type ii
fibers to decrease 10% obviously if you
would take more time off it would likely
be a significant decrease but
nonetheless we're seeing a small
decrease here after these 30 weeks off
but then when they start to train again
for 6 weeks we're seeing the hypertrophy
occur again muscle muscle mass increase
again so it just goes to drive home the
point again as we saw in the previous
couple slides that yes you are going to
lose size and strength but it's not
going to be killer and this has been
seen for a long time if we go back to
this 91 study and then we go back to the
blahs of this study that was done and
about the past decade or so so the data
is in agreement there now lastly I want
to talk about briefly before we go into
our sample program why this occurs and
there's gonna be some conflicting
evidence on this so I want to show this
one paper here because this is kind of
one of the more foundational papers from
2004 but there is a paper that's just
out really recently in the last month or
so that is questioning kind of this
hypothesis or these findings so I think
there is conflicting data in the area
but nonetheless we've covered a mass
before so if you can think back to the
concept of my own nuclear edition so
with my own nuclear edition we've talked
about how I portray occurs one because
of protein synthesis but two because
when satellite cells are activated a
nuclei from satellite cells can be
donated to a myofiber and when a
myofiber has more my own nuclei it tends
to support a larger larger area if you
will each nuclei can only support so
much domain or so much area so when
additional nuclei is added it can
support more area and the myofiber
can grow so that comes from satellite
cells so when there's more satellite
cells around a myofiber that tends to
mean that individual I was a greater
propensity for growth someone that has a
fewer amount of satellite cells or
myofiber has a lower potential for
growth there might be a low responder to
training hyah - ah delay cells might be
a higher respond attract so with that
said this study from caddie in 2004
looks at 90 days of training and 90 days
of D training in men and so if we look
at fiber area or muscle size head perch
B here we can see hypertrophy occurs
from pre to ninety days of training now
after the D training we can see a
decrease in fiber size that's all the
way up to the 90 days D training so a 90
days D training here this is
significantly lower than it was when
they ended the 90 days of training if we
go over to the right we're gonna see a
somewhat similar graph when looking at
satellite cell number per fiber so if
you remember we just talked about how
satellite cells somebody has more
satellite cells they can donate more my
own nuclei have a greater propensity for
growth so we see an increase in the
number of satellite cells per fiber at
90 days but a decrease here close to
back to baseline after 90 days of D
training so after 90 days of D training
here we are seeing that and that this
bar here is pretty similar to this one
so a pretty similar trend here up and
down and up and down so the authors
noted here that one of the reasons that
hyper tree my hair muscle size might go
down here and the D training is because
of satellite cell number and thus my own
nuclei number going down so that being
said there is some conflicting evidence
on the maintenance of Maia nuclei some
data is showing that even during a time
of D training and when there is a loss
of muscle size that my own nucleon
number remains similar or doesn't go all
the way back down to baseline and miss
that I just show that my nuclear number
or satellite cell number Falls pretty
far so the decrease in satellite cell
number where my own nuclei could be a
mechanism that that causes the decrease
in a per tree of D training but we're
not 100% sure on that this is hopefully
helping to explain or to give you one
hypothesis why that may occur so if you
could maintain your satellite cell
number during D training hopefully that
could help maintain muscle size but
again we're not
entirely chef so where does this leave
you for getting the mechanistic stuff
for a moment the decrease in muscle size
and the decreased strength that occurred
puts you not back to baseline and then
regaining you pretty quickly meaning you
do decrease muscle size and you do
decrease strength that you can make that
back so although the data does show
quicker regaining specifically the
starand study although they only took
six weeks have I received news thirty
weeks of D training and only six weeks
of training which is why I think that
was a bit fast and how they gained it
but I would take into account training
status and say in the staring study the
women were trained but not super well
trained so they probably regained it a
little bit more quickly but something to
be cautious would say if you take four
or five months off and this is using the
data and being a little bit cautious on
my part so it's not an exact exact
timeframe but it's based upon the data
and then saying hey just to make sure
nobody leaves this video thinking they
can gain all their strength back in a
week being a little cautious so you take
four to five months off the probably
takes about two to four months to regain
so about three months off you know to
three months to be able to regain so in
the grand scheme of things it's really
not that much time I try to stress a lot
and think about training in terms of
let's say 20 years or 25 years right if
you're in this and you're a member of
mass you know training is important to
you and it's something you're probably
gonna do for a long time and so in that
case I would say if you have to take a
few months off now but you know you you
have 20 more years to Train it's really
not gonna matter that much just as last
month we talked about if you wanted to
run a marathon certainly that's not
going to be ideal for your powerlifting
progress or your bodybuilding progress
in the short term but if you have twenty
more years to Train you're gonna be fine
you might as well do it in have some fun
so mechanistically we talked about
possible contribution of satellite cell
nuclei number but certainly there's
neuromuscular changes fiber type
adaptations not only the decrease in
size but from a strength perspective the
shifting of the fiber inter conversions
that you're gonna see away from type 2
to X toward type 1 if you stopped
training and then with a loss of loss of
skill adaptation I'm sure we've seen
this if you don't go out for a while you
don't deadlift for
you don't bench for a while and you go
back to it the movement just feels
uncomfortable at first rate of force
development is probably lower as well so
all of those things are going to harm
strength which is why I suggest that the
skilled lifts may see a greater
detriment in strength from time off than
the non skilled lifts if you're doing
the leg extension or a leg press or
something like that it doesn't take so
much skill as a squad so you don't have
the the skill aspect of it in terms of
technique all you have is the
neuromuscular aspect of it so where does
this leave you it leaves you in the fact
that you're gonna lose some size and
strength but it's not gonna be as much
as you think but you also need to
consider that when you return even if
you haven't lost as much strength as you
thought or as much size as you thought
you're going to be more susceptible to
muscle damage meaning you're gonna have
greater fatigue that occurs when you
start to train again right and your
neural adaptations have diminished and
they can be renewing regain quickly but
if we just focus on these top two damage
and fatigue even if you haven't lost as
much strength as you thought or as much
size as you thought when you come back
to training you haven't done it for
three months so if you haven't done
something for three months it's going to
fatigue you a lot more easily than it
used to you're not completely back to
baseline after one training bout to
repeat about if that can last for up to
six months right but the degree to which
the repeated bad effect occurs from
today to next week is a lot greater than
the degree which it occurs from today to
three months from now so you're going to
be susceptible to damage so you have to
take that into account you're going to
want to start back with very little if
you did nothing and I like to say this a
lot too if you did nothing for three
months and now you just do something it
will work and so what we're gonna
propose here in the sample program at
first isn't gonna seem like very much
training but remember doing nothing and
now doing something is a lot I always
give the example you know I went a long
time without ever playing basketball or
shooting free-throws
I shoot free-throws in my driveway every
single day now I'm still terrible but
I'm infinitely better than I was a year
ago because now I'm actually playing
right so I was doing nothing and now I'm
doing something right I'm still terrible
but reule
to where I was I'm better so if you
don't live for three months and then you
just do a little bit you will make
progress so your previous numbers don't
matter
you shouldn't used percentages to start
because you don't know where your maxes
are we can estimate you can use our PE
but even at first I don't want to run
the risk of overshooting it too much so
what I like to do is just a program
absurdly light loads so when we go
through this program we're gonna give an
example program and we're gonna give
what this person's numbers were before
they went on their three-month hiatus
and then we're gonna give you the
absolute numbers in this program and
you're gonna see how light they are and
we'll go through a 12-week program to
get us back so the goal with this
program or 13 week program I should say
I ended up adding a thirteenth week so I
wanted to get a little taper in there
but a 13 week retraining program
following 12 weeks or three months of D
training so roughly three months of D
training and then roughly three months
of retraining so during this three
months of retraining
this might not get you all the way back
right and but it could get you pretty
close and remember this is just one
example so anytime I put together a
sample program I think it's always
important as a reminder that I'm just
giving an example of how to do things
this isn't the only way to do it this
isn't the exact program that I would
write for everyone and I think everyone
here knows that it's just rather kind of
an example of saying hey if this is what
you've done and and it's taking a
specific person right this person
doesn't actually exist but I've created
a training block that this person was
doing before they went on their
three-month hiatus so based upon that
that's how we're creating a retraining
program so whatever program you were
doing or whatever level you were at you
would want to take all of these
principles and then apply them to you so
our pre D training program that we're
going to see in a moment this individual
is benching and squatting three times
per week about twelve sets and ten sets
respectively and then developed in twice
a week for eight sets and then
appropriate assistance work and so forth
so about ten more sets after that per
muscle group around 20 sets or so for
some of the muscle groups a little more
a little less for others now this for
individual we're gonna say they have a
dual focus they definitely want to get
stronger but they've got a lot of volume
in there
and you focus on hypertrophy as well so
kind of a dual focus here so this is the
pre D training program this person is
training a lot training six days per
week you can see benching three times a
week as we said Monday Wednesday and
Friday and then squatting Saturday
excuse me on Tuesday Thursday and
Saturday in an undulating fashion rp4
some lifts using some various assistance
movements and all of the programming
tools that we've talked about in math so
far they're all in this program it's a
very similar starting program to what I
showed last month in the concurrent
marathon video and then off of that we
worked the program to get ready for the
marathon off of this this kind of
standard program for this person we're
gonna work retraining so somebody did
this let's say their max is on this 225
kilos which is about 496 and pounds if
you work in pounds one hundred and forty
kilos on bench that's about three
hundred eight pounds I believe and then
deadlift 230 which I believe is five
hundred and seven pounds so this
person's you know pretty strong pretty
good base they've definitely been
training for a while and so if they have
these numbers and it's important to
remember those numbers because we're
going to kind of use some lower
percentages of those as we're working
back so this is what this person was
doing pretty high volume program
training the lifts frequently training a
lot putting a lot of assistance work in
there and so let's see how we would
retrain so they did this and then they
had three months off and now we're gonna
write a three month program to get them
back so the first two weeks just do
something nothing strenuous at all these
are your very first two weeks back from
taking three months off and it's one
thing to say that we take three months
off but actually think about it for a
moment
you did not touch a weight for three
months that's a long time even if you
didn't lose as much strength and size as
you thought you're really gonna be
susceptible fatigue when you start back
so we're only gonna train three total
days in the first two weeks right each
week is gonna be three days so six total
days for the two weeks but three
training days per week you could
definitely get away with less than that
I should say as well even if you only
train once or twice but a frequency of
once on the main list in the first week
and then getting to a frequency
twice on the main list in the second
week is what we're going to do in this
first couple weeks and then as we said
earlier we're not going to use
percentages we're gonna program absolute
loads in week 1 and absolute loads in
week 2 and be really conservative but
you're gonna see even when we say twice
a week in week 2 it's really easy so
remember previously this individual
could max squat 225 kilos bench 140 and
deadlift 230 now our first week back so
week 1 is up here I'll circle it here
with the person training three times per
week you can see squatting just once
benching just once dead lifting just
once they could squat 225 kilos their
first week back three sets of five 65
kilograms
I know it's absurdly light I know they
could do a lot more even if they could
only you know max a hundred and seventy
kilos and they used to be able to do 225
65 kilos is exactly 65 more kilos and
they had squatted any day for the past
three months so it's a really really
light load this is off of whatever their
projected new max would be which we'll
look at in a moment this is 30
percentage something like that maybe a
little bit less I'm certainly like the
assistants work is staying in a 5 RP or
less just a couple sets of rows here
again even though this is really light
it might cause some fatigue and soreness
for the next couple days cuz they have
literally done nothing bench press again
working at 50 kilos they could have done
one 40 before really like just putting a
couple assistance movements in there
nothing strenuous at all
deadlift just singles at 70 kilos and
make a deadlift 230 right there just
putting one red and no collar on the bar
some leg extensions and they're just one
set of lateral raises really really easy
it looks like you're not doing anything
but the goal over the first two weeks
was just do something I'm gonna hit on
this next to refrain a few more times
but when you're doing something like
this you're going to want to do more
right if you've taken time off it
usually it takes one or two days and
then you're kind of motivated you want
to do more don't write only bad things
can come from that if you follow
something gradual after taking time off
it's going to work you got to trust the
process and you got
stick with and it's gonna work if you
want to jump up and do more just because
you can do it doesn't mean you should do
it so from there we go into week two and
week two you can see on squat went from
sixty five kilos to 80 kilos here now
you can see at the end of the week we've
added a second day of squatting these
six reps at 80 kilos probably aren't
going to cause much soreness at all
because we've elicited the repeated bad
effect now and also what we've done is
we've tried to quote protect against
muscle damage so when you look at the
repeated bad effect by performing such a
light load what that does is it causes a
minimal amount of damage but just enough
because so that way then ultimately
there's recovery of skeletal muscle and
there's repair skeletal muscle and it's
more resistant to fatigue here so we'd
also call that protecting against damage
so now we've added a second day of
squatting in here but it's still
absurdly light it's just doubles here
working on a four to five hour PE and
then this is just a guy that's working
up to 100 kilos the reason I put this in
here is I would I would ask this person
to cap it at 100 kilos so even if
they're double at a 4 to 5 RP was above
that it gives them a cap say hey don't
go above that that's as much as I want
you to do so in week 2 we're still
working at absurdly light loads here
we've added a second day of bench press
in here as well you can see bumping up
to 65 kilos on the sixes day and then
some doubles here capping them at 85
kilos on the bench or a number again
they could bench 140 before so this is
still really really light and even
though we've gone to a frequency of
twice a week it's not really a full
frequency of twice a week it's still
absurdly light here on this day in this
other day is just doubles that really
light loads as well and then we have a
little bit more assistance where we've
added a set of curls here we've added a
set of pull-ups from two to three and so
forth but these first two weeks are pure
intro weeks you're just doing something
you're conferring the repeat about
effect and protecting against muscle
damage you're gonna want to do more
don't stick to the plan so just doing
something here one thing and I said we'd
get to this is you know I would probably
take something like seventy five percent
of your previous 1rm if you wanted to
predict some numbers and so the old
numbers for 225 75% of that would be 170
140 we go to 105 per bench and 230 we go
to 170 two and a half I think this
person might be stronger than this
remember if you look at the blossom itch
and the staring studies the percentage
decreases in strength after three months
off
we're actually less than this they were
only about maybe 15% or so they weren't
as much as 25% but I do think it's good
to be cautious I'm taking into account
that a lot of people watching this are
gonna be more trained than the people
that were used in those studies I just
don't want anybody to overshoot so if
you did this I think it's probably a
conservative calculation but I bring
that to light because that means we're
working between 30 and 60% or weeks one
and two you know the exception of the
double at a five bar P in week two but
even that's around 60% ish meaning that
we're not doing anything crazy here
right everything is very very light so
you were doing nothing now you were
doing something it is definitely not too
light so after this though we go two
weeks three and four so I don't think
we're doing real training yet but I
think we're progressing to real train
weeks three and four is kind of a bridge
to what I would call your first training
block so we're still doing intro so we
kind of had one introductory microcycle
on weeks 1 & 2 now we're gonna have
another introductory microcycle on weeks
3 & 4 then our first real training block
will start in week 5 so now we're gonna
train a total of 4 times per week
training tunnel three times per week
before working up to a frequency of
twice a week oh and everything adding it
a little bit more assistance work and
gradually increase intensity so that
you're gradually moving things up so
again before we had three total training
days now we have four so we can see
squat here and squat here this is twice
a week then we have bench here and bench
here that's twice a week and now you can
include it another day of deadlifting
and just a little bit more assistance
work but everything is really light
still so squat three sets of seven at
100 kilos so again I'm still programming
the exact loads sometimes in this case
we know right I'm choosing loads that I
know are still absurdly light that this
person can do without issue that are
still going to cause adaptation right
even though it's really light doesn't
mean it's not causing adaptation this
still qualifies as progressive over look
this person on squat had done 5s at 60
and then sixes and I believe whatever we
program the next week was about 85 kilos
now they're doing sevens on 100 that's
still progressive overload so rather
than having them use RP a 3 by 7 at 5 to
7 or 5 to 8 RP e I know if I'm doing
that at this point coming back I'm gonna
overshoot the RPS or even if I'm hitting
the RPS I'm just gonna go so high up and
weight that it's just not it's just not
necessary yet I don't need it so this
still qualifies as progressive overload
so I would still utilize this then for
the second day of squatting I'm just
working singles here but I'm doing
progressively heavier singles why I'm
trying to now facilitate those
neuromuscular adaptations that were lost
by gradually getting into some heavier
loads
same thing on bench one day here some
higher higher reps but from easier load
here it's still causing progressive
overload higher load more reps and they
were previously doing and then
increasing some singles up to some
decent intensities trying to facilitate
those neuromuscular adaptations and I'm
starting to add in some assistance work
the RPS are really low fours and fives 5
to 7 for just a couple sets but the
reason being in our next block and week
5 we're gonna start doing some
assistance work as part of our first
real block so we want to make sure that
we're having enough work here so we're
not so susceptible when we go into a
little bit more volume and then down
here in week 4 the only real difference
here is that everything is sur sure it's
progressed a little bit and I've chosen
to progress instead of 3 by 7 at 100
instead of all of these to 105 just one
set.i 105 peak intensity is more
important than average so again not
doing too much and then there's a single
at a six to a seven hour piece so now in
week four we're finally getting into
programming something here really with
RP on the main lifts and I've put in the
parentheses in red about what I would
expect this person to hit at that point
just so we could kind of calculate some
numbers and see where they might be so a
single out of six to seven maybe about
180 180 kilos about 396 pounds remember
they could squat for 96 or 225 before so
this is probably gonna put them around a
max of somewhere in the the you know 200
190 to 200 ish range so they're still
gonna be considerably below where they
were but I think they can start to get
back there and start working on some
singles to facilitate some neuromuscular
adaptations so just gradually increasing
I would call this two weeks
the second introductory micro cycle or
progressing to real training getting
back to some sense of normalcy and so
everything we just said we did there
twice a week frequency but the one time
a week is really really light so it's
not two volume days yet we took our time
on all of this and we're gradually
building to get into our first real
block so the first real block I would
call this getting four weeks away from
normalcy right we're getting back to
where we were we're getting closer I
still don't think this person is ready
to fully jump back into everything and
even if they are I don't think it's
necessary so I still think you should
take advantage of some time because
you're only in week five here where you
can still progress on doing a lot less
work than you used to
so training four times per week here and
I put this in capitals now because I'm
yelling at you but because I just want
to know that this is a true two time per
week frequency meaning to full volume
days in this block not the two times a
week frequency we had in the
introductory micro cycle where it was
one volume day and then one just singles
day of really really low intensity so
meaning we have more of a challenging
intensity here and now we're beginning
to use our P's because it's starting to
get okay to push things a little bit
more we don't need to just program
they're really really light loads
they're not going to do as much for us
in terms of adaptation we're at a point
now after a full four weeks have gone by
where we can use our p and challenge
ourselves a bit so four day per week
training walker weeks five to eight so
if you notice this individual was using
RP
before they did the d training to to
program their loads so we have bench
here 3 by 8 at five data are P and then
bench over here four by four at six day
at our P and then a single here and I'll
explain that in a moment but if we take
three for that seven and then one that's
eight that's Kate sets a bench when they
were doing the block before the D
training they did twelve sets of bench
so we are gradually climbing back toward
that twelve sets and in the next block
that starts
week ten we're gonna see that we go a
frequency on the bench press and the
squad of three times per week so we're
still two times a week here but when we
go to three times per week that'll help
us facilitate more volume thus we'll
bump it back up to around the twelfth
mark and so if we just focus on bench
for a moment then we have the same thing
on squat what we've done here is we've
added one single at an 8 RP that's not
too strenuous but all of this here is
between a 6 and 8 RP and this is between
a 5 and 8 RP and the assistants work is
submaximal so the reason for the one
single is just to have some
neuromuscular adaptations to help with
greater force development and we've
talked about some heavier singles here
in math before I think the single will
progress really well every week during
this block because you just weren't
working up to anything heavy at all and
if you haven't done anything in a while
or any heavy work in a while and you
start to do some singles I think you
notice progress pretty quickly so that's
the point of it here but it's not too
strenuous and it's probably not going to
be as heavy as it would it be otherwise
because you're doing it after the volume
work and then the same principles apply
on squat we have that on Tuesday and on
Friday on deadlift here I have singles
at 70 to 80% of the new projected max we
projected the max previously because we
were able to go ahead and take that
single on deadlift at a 6 to 7 our p 190
you can go ahead and we've done this in
math if you have velocity you can
predict a one around if you have the
Epley equation you can predict the one
around something like that
and so I would take about 70 to 80
percentage of this if you prefer to use
RP you can say somewhere between a 5 to
a 6 or 5 to 7 RP for your singles and
then we've added some assistance work
here if you notice so even though we've
added some assistance work it's still
not too too difficult you know six to
eight RPS a couple seven & 9s mixed in
some 5 to 7 s here since 5 to 8 early on
in the block so just doing a little bit
more in preparing for kind of the next
block to come after this but gradually
getting things a little bit higher some
singles to get some neuromuscular work
and so again the first time here we're
two full volume days is in our fifth
full week back and the first time here
we were using harpy and challenging
ourselves
more rather than programming absurdly
late loads is in our fifth week black
back so I think that this is a a key
block force here this week five to eight
because there's some first here in terms
of full volume days and finally getting
rid of the absurdly late loads and some
heavier singles but still our volume is
much lower than when we started training
about four sets lower on bench we said
twelve sets before the D training and
now eight sets and still we have only
two days a week frequency instead of
three on the main level so after that
instead of jumping into the next block
because we we did do a lot more on weeks
five to eight than we did in weeks one
to four so you took three months off so
one week of taper slash intro isn't
going to hurt you it's just preparing
you because the next block I think we're
about ready to go back to almost full
force with three times a week frequency
and getting our volume back up there so
between weeks eight and ten and week
nine do an intro a week three times per
week frequency though so if we were only
doing two times a week frequency before
with two volume days
I think this taper intro is a great time
to start to introduce three times a week
frequency but one of the days is really
really light and it prepares you for the
next block so let's take a look so if we
take that squat look at squat we have
our squat here and we can see three sets
of five using our P climb five six and
seven RP on each step and then at the
end of the week we can see three sets of
three at five to seven remember this is
a taper this is an intro week five to
seven RP is really easy but what this
taper allows us to do with these easy
loads as we've put a third day of
squatting in and a third day of benching
a quote power or light day three singles
that 75% of the projected max that you
would make or that you would get with
heavy singles that you took at the end
of the previous block at the ARP II so
adding some assistance working here just
to prepare this week should be little
easy and light but obviously even though
it's lighter it's gonna give you a rest
you're probably gonna feel more
recovered and you've introduced a new
day of training a new frequency you're
going to three times a week so you're
certainly not going to get weaker from
doing the central week now we go into
what I would call back to normal
training and we
10 to 13 right so this will be the last
mesocycle of the block than we look at
here today training total of six times
per week with the true frequency meaning
three volume days of three times per
week on the squad and Ventris is exactly
what we were doing on the previous
before the D training and then I finally
start to add in some integrated
periodization to allow for some heavy
work and hopefully push the one arounds
back to where they were and I do think
that's possible after these 13 weeks so
if we look at this last block here this
should say week 10 to 13 but if we look
at this last block we can see now take
bench for sets RP is a little higher
over here we have four sets and then
over here we have four more sets a
double here a heavy double and then
three sets of volume that brings us back
to our twelve sets that we weren't
previously so let's just focus on the
bench for a moment and the squat and
then we'll get any assistance movements
and the deadlift but if we look at that
we can see bench kind of in an
undulating fashion eight reps here five
reps here again this isn't a requirement
for anybody it's just how I like to
program and then if we go down here what
I've done is this block is at the end of
the week on the squad bench
there's a heavy edge double and in the
next few weeks it's going to transition
to a heavy edge single again to
facilitate those neuromuscular
adaptations now that we're getting in
enough volume here this is much more
volume than we were doing so there still
is room and this is what I'm talking
about the integrated periodization
strategies to still put in some heavy
work and facilitate neuromuscular
adaptations and again if you haven't
done heavy things this is going to
consistently push up your your max
pretty quickly in a short time span the
same thing on squat here deadlift is
getting a little bit higher using the
projected max an 80% one day and 85
percent in the first week of this block
or week 10 and we've added in a lot more
assistance work now still some max some
maximal are peas but some of them are
getting up there a little bit higher we
have some seven nine seer in terms of
the RPS and we're definitely adding more
sets four sets of curls four sets of
rows here on this day you know back is
being trained about three times a week
here shoulders about two to three times
a week so we're definitely increasing
the amount of assistance work we're
doing and we're pretty much back to norm
with the exception of I'm still trying
to to push up that 1rm a little bit so
we are using some submaximal doubles and
then go to singles in the next few weeks
this block to get those neuromuscular
adaptations so back to normal and this
block what I want to highlight on this
slide is I'm circling in the cursor here
is that I showed you week 10 in week 11
12 and 13 remember in week 10 there was
a double at an 8 to 9 on squat and bench
I would gradually progress that day to
get the neuromuscular adaptations and
push up the one around and week 11 I
would probably have a single item 8 to 9
I'm squatting bench and single at 87
half percent on the deadlift or 3
singles it was 85 percent in week 10
so that's gradually increasing again the
same 810 INR PE I still think you're
gonna be able to increase load from week
11 to 12 no problem because this is
still a new stimulus and then working up
to deadlift single out an 8 to 9 on week
12 so we're finally getting closer being
able to really feel comfortable pushing
heavy weights and working close to a 1
around then week 13 and 8 and a half to
nine and a half hour P single and Squad
bench and deadlift working through 9 9
and 1/2 kind of getting finally your
year three months into this the
retraining which was the exact time the
D training was and can you get back to
where you were in 3 months and I think
if you use the strategy you can kind of
get some neuromuscular adaptations and
and push those lifts up there toward the
end of this training block so some
thoughts and wisdom from doing this
typically I don't take a whole lot of
time off from training just to take it
although certainly at times that have
been busy in my life and I've had to and
you know we all have little injuries and
things and so forth some from had from
time to time but I have had times where
I've had to come back from being off for
a couple months or so and so if you go
through something like this just from
from being there and I'm sure many many
people watching this video I've been
there as well just do something it will
cause progress you will progress quickly
as well right if you can think back to
when you first started the training
years ago or maybe you're kind of in the
early stages of your training career now
it's really fun right you start to gain
pretty quickly you're going to do that
so enjoy it
right
if you want to do more don't do it you
know stick to the plan if you get past
the first three months or so if you've
been off for three months and I think
that's a pretty good rule as long as
you've been off if once you've started
training for that amount of time again
and then you start to want to do more
and push it or go off the plan it's okay
but if you're within those first three
months and you've got three months off
don't do more than you're supposed to
you're going to make progress because
you did nothing and now you do something
so enjoy that now once you get past
these three months and you're making
really fast progress you're not gonna
expect the same progress in the next
block after this right that's when
you're probably gonna start to level off
a little bit so temper your expectations
right and if you're new to training
you're probably making all of this
progress now but it's not gonna last
forever
right so temper your expectations so
applications and takeaways again
following months of D training you will
lose size and strength but it's probably
not as much as you think when you start
back work gradually and understand that
your previous number simply don't apply
if you start back the first week and say
well it's quite to 2504 and so you know
I've done 175 for 12 so you know I'll
just do one 75 kilos for a bunch of
fives on my first day I should still be
able to do that don't do it could you do
it even that that's probably a little
much probably not but even if you could
don't do it your previous numbers do not
apply program some absurdly light loads
and start back don't do more than you
need to and then just stay calm and
focus your adaptations will come back
and it won't take that long you know I
can't stress this enough if you do plan
on training for many many years and I'm
sure a lot of us do then it's gonna get
there right you just have to be patient
with it it's not easy and I break that
rule all the time myself so it's more of
a you know do as I say not as I do type
of thing because I'm not a very good
coach with myself but you know if you
can't stay patient stay calm and stay
focused and trust that this gradual
process will work it ultimately will
work and then there will be a time to
push it and go off plan later on but but
not in the first few months that you're
coming back lastly I just wanted to say
on the bottom is slide and in the blue
font that this video isn't looking at
coming back from an injury not a
physical therapist and I think there are
some really cool strategies coming back
from injury whether it's
around manipulating the movement and
doing if you know if you can't squat
during the box squad or doing the some
portion of the movement that you can and
then when you can do the movement using
a lighter load you know working on slow
eccentric stew make sure you're not
overloading too much in the early stages
of coming back you know the
biopsychosocial model of pain is very
interesting
however it's not something I consider
myself to be an expert on I'm not a
physical therapist so I just want to
stay back because they don't want
anybody watching this to think that this
applies to everything or it applies from
someone to coming back from an injury if
you're coming back from an injury you're
certainly gonna probably have to modify
exercises consult with your physical
therapist and I would probably let them
lead the way if you're just coming back
from time off that's what this video
applies to but I really enjoy making
this one I've enjoyed the last couple
months kind of putting together these
sample programs and to provide some
really practical takeaways some
practical programs that you guys can
take out of this and manipulate to be
specific to you or takes a program that
we have here and take that and go ahead
and use it so hopefully you guys enjoy
that I'll try to keep doing that type of
thing to give you guys information that
you can put into practice right away
as always it's an honor and a pleasure
to do this and I will see you guys next
month